uh one of the best days of my life
um first of all congratulations to
brownie on on his decision he made
um you know I'm super proud of him our
family is proud of him
um for me personally
it's even more special to me because
it's the first time uh someone out of my
family to go to college
obviously I didn't go to college either
so it's just a proud moment to see my
son go to college and he's the first one
to go to college in my family so um
super duper proud super emotional but
just super super duper uh excited and
happy for his journey and uh today was a
proud day uh I couldn't lose today no
matter the amount of the outcome of this
game I couldn't lose today personally so
but I'll take this uh this cherry on top
of this dub though